this week we've got mistaken socks idiot
flier and animal rescue can I tell you
that over the weekend Steve was so sweet
I was on a trip and he's like I got you
your socks from downstairs in the
laundry he gave me four socks
not one of them matched we're all
completely different socks and I was
like okay none of these match and he's
like oh [ __ ] I'm a rectifier this well
this they were clean socks girls yeah
there were claims true it would be more
[ __ ] that they were all dirty songs
they're all missing like they're all
four different no just probably grab a
pink stripe
that's a yellow strap that's crazy that
yeah that many different like I only
have two pairs of socks
they're either low-cut socks and they
all match or they're taller socks at me
oh you're calling her crazy yours is
crazy
no why matter they all match that's a
point if you just stick your hands in
the hamper and pull two out chances are
they're gonna match but I like these are
Puma these are champions these are well
and there's different cuts like look I'm
wearing these ones cuz I don't want my
so don't want my socks to show and it
along with there's some low-cut side
maybe my sock game sucks
I need buy more socks yeah so don't call
me crazy finest trunk um she's pretty
crazy
I am who says you can't wear mismatched
socks though that's not that bothers
this bother how does it feel the same
have you tried wearing like finger like
toe socks yeah and the one that goes
past her never oh are you from 2001 with
the toe socks yeah don't hand me over
the toe shoes came around like recently
but I hate though like junior high but
yet there were toe socks to wear the toe
shoes oh do you know my socks
that's nasty we got three articles to
talk about you know that
what are these mistaken sauce about
three are on topic for the first story
this may go back to Steve them so he's
from Japan so maybe joking really we got
ninja songs like this okay traveling
maybe Joe can translate this video that
I'm going to show you but he walked it
uh-huh
he walked in on his grandma just
relaxing on the bed just chillin
okay and he notices what's on her feet
and he was like oh my god those were
actually his condoms sex toys on her
yeah like like a flashlight
exactly no no she might be seen on that
dimension play the video
oh [ __ ] cute why does he have a pair
of answer and then you had to stop
nobody no not to my grandma what is all
your feet she's like socks that there
were thermal socks she was like socks
and he's like where did you find them in
your room in the dresser or something
like that yeah yeah I see underneath I
can I see what do you think like it's
okay you could borrow it
the Copic is silicon e that [ __ ] is so
that's it but that yeah that's it but
their other socks underneath this joke
about that because I thought yeah watch
out watch out how does she get that [ __ ]
on it was so tight wait what she was
thinking her circulation - it's like
they're like a flashlight thing - Levi
Beth why did he have two of them and
they match for his pair of dicks yeah
maybe he swaps them out oh maybe well
what's dirty give them yeah where they
both clean
Rosalie I'm pretty [ __ ] sure she has
like dementia or something cuz the way
she was talking was kind of like a child
like his grandma like you know in
Chinese culture you give the red
envelopes well he gave one to his
grandma and she was trying to eat it and
then she was like no no no oh there was
money in there the opening part of it
looks like vagina doesn't look like her
vagina lips maybe that's why her she's a
little saggy geared now bet so you ended
up telling her what it was and she was
just like oh okay like you told her I
put my penis through this I don't know
your [ __ ] this grandma I bought this I
don't know exactly what he said but I
mean she probably put it in this way to
she's like oh look how convenient oh the
backside yeah it's not the [ __ ] it's
like this way she turned it heavy for
her foot to go in there's two she's like
this is warm natural thorough off there
are two matching things they are a
different color but cute he's got the
[ __ ] you're like a [ __ ] dude
it'd be funny if there are different
colored [ __ ] like one was a black
[ __ ] where his different fetishes what
a good sense of humor - I know she's
just like okay for him to to want to
record it he's like I got a good that's
pretty funny that's ballsy all right for
our next story this first-time flyer
thought that she could get on the plane
by by getting onto the conveyor belt
that takes the luggage
I wish how did she even get on there
check again I'll show you how she got on
issue from the back country back country
yeah I'm liking me off from the front
country you know
I picture her you know like that [ __ ]
machine she runs up inside through the
where the bag get dropped off oh she's
like she's not even moving because it
keeps coming down yeah oh she's she's
living in the future
she is 2029 for sure yeah I went to
Australia where like they just all bill
pay with the tapping like credit cards
and we still have to do the insertion
she's living in the future we're just
going this gave up with the luggage
she used that as an excuse everybody
wants to get on there fella to man I'll
show you wanna be a stowaway the
security video
this takes place in a Turkish airport I
heard it gets really cold and you can
die oh my god fast alright so she didn't
see any other people go on there she's a
society that's where you put the
suitcases lady you don't even walk cause
like I'm ready she was like oh here's
the luggage they didn't even tell her
don't go there people we're looking at
her like you don't think you have to
tell anyone don't go there you're like
maybe she dropped her watch down there
and she's looking for it a bit is this
actually happening right now yeah
everyone's faces were like cuz so out of
the norm like they're probably just
registering it in the moment like we're
in no way no way wait what the [ __ ] yeah
look at everyone's reaction even this
guy was staring right that's actually a
lot of space if you think about it cuz
usually it's enough space for luggage
yeah can we get on like that though like
can we change it yeah cuz that would be
way more fun yeah and then you just sit
there and you just get scan like I would
volunteer to just scat me as I sit there
but I'll be dull and then they just take
you to the airplane they just extend the
people movers they see 30 there so
that's the seat on the bow
Disneyland ride like in the haunted
house
you know what's dog about the Toronto
Airport you know how like when you're
walking there's usually that flat
escalator thing so for people like the
people mover yeah I think that the speed
Walker thing goes about the same speed
as someone that speed walking there's
two of them in Toronto and the one on
the far Lane it's like that's a sprinter
one I was on the speed walking fee and I
was blogging I was filming the guy past
me that's what just flew right house and
he was taking a movie we're just
standing like this Michael Jackson Lee -
[ __ ] it that [ __ ] was crazy
is everyone like shipment of the come on
[Laughter]
[Applause]
Jason chance girlfriend girlfriend
[Laughter]
there's three choices right I'm in the
middle and she's like what the joke do
you get why we're laughing that I was
checking her out yeah yeah that's what
it sounded like okay okay now I was a
chick around you were so focused on her
that you couldn't pay attention to it no
I was so focused on why she had to walk
when there's fast and faster so she was
trying to catch up with everyone I
really want to know what they look like
when they get on yeah because YouTube
videos of it is [ __ ] it's really [ __ ]
fast like it's like isn't it dangerous
though it's that I really look I guess
people that are not in America aren't as
dumb as Americans so maybe they don't
they get like they see and they're like
oh that does look dangerous I'm not
gonna do it but then it can be a
slippery slope because then like so like
say some one person trips it's going too
fast you'll do like recover
pretty bad I wish they had that next to
sidewalks so that you could just like
have an alternative to driving there
should be a conveyor belt see we could
just jump on and it takes you yeah I
played that I played that level in like
Mario Party right you enter the address
in it just takes you what is a conveyor
belt all over the city going both ways
and you could just step on it and you
jump on it takes you that's what they're
trying to do with the Hyperloop like
underground tunnel for the Tesla yeah
yeah you know I would like a train
system for just me and my friends she's
in the future she's got it yeah bus
everybody everyone saw that and was like
don't do oh yeah but I love Gio's idea
or you could just sit on your own seat
and I've takes you all yeah the security
check all of that yeah and then through
the plane hands up wouldn't it be dope
if there was like a pod so you go in and
it's like a pod and then the pod just
takes you everywhere and it locks you in
the airplane and everything that's what
you say Oh in a pot oh well he levelled
it up one was the pet bought the pod I'm
imagining there's food Oh everything
there it's like wall-e wall-e yeah
everything are the Jetsons yeah me and
then you do like a like a different like
themes so it's like one looks feel like
you're in a roller coaster
Oh Star Wars and you just have a 3d
glasses off so you think you're or
you're in different places yeah where
the screen is oh yeah because that makes
me dizzy sometimes me too my face is
always too small for those glasses or
mm-hmm
so we just press a button and then it
turns into Jurassic Park or whatever
maybe now why even travel exactly you
could just go to Hawaii every day that's
true
why even move all right for our last
story this man from Utah was chilling in
his home with his homey and they were
drinking and all of a sudden that's when
they heard or saw this tiny little baby
bird that just fell out of the sky they
were like what the [ __ ] oh my gosh this
baby needs help but we're too drunk to
drive it - OH
cherien yeah so the the wildlife rehab
rehab center and so what they ended up
joking they were like oh we kind of be
so funny if we call uber wait what if we
call it Oh Bert for the bird and that's
what ended up happening oh cool uber for
this tiny little baby bird and they
ended up rescuing it so they call the
uber and they told to over take it to
the [ __ ] Humane Society I take that
take out all of us no just the bird does
the baby what a dreamy music as it was
just the bird I never was like sure yeah
oh yeah so that's what they're saying -
like luckily that uber was on board with
it they're just like okay sure I'll take
it so the uber driver just had a baby
bird passenger and that was it all right
uber driver obviously took it up to the
building just like hey get out or stop
get out they couldn't pick a better
picture for the bird the bird looks so
angry it does there's another one
it was just like a newborn baby bird I
don't know it looks pretty because what
happens is these birds do fall out of
their nests which means the nest is
nearby or the momma's gonna pick it up
yeah to remove the bird not really know
unless there's like the hawk or and
other animals that are like but then
what about that thing that they say that
is if you touch a baby bird that the mom
would smell it I think I've heard that
for every single species of animal or
but yeah so then like the I don't if the
birds have that so don't touch them like
don't put them back because I mean if
they're not in like eminent danger or if
you don't see any like predators around
it you just leave it alone and the mom
will tend to it because I like birds
build nests in areas where I mean it's
away from humans or other predators so
they hide and then sometimes he's
British the moms out getting high hoeing
around they did a good thing by
abandoned you know very truth Shadowrun
Akana there might be a really good bird
mom at the Humane Society that's willing
to take care of that bird yeah his
adoptive parents in line yeah hands like
a bird yeah I wonder what the
conversation was with that goober driver
and like the the vets yeah yeah I don't
know
they're just cause drunk people it sound
ridiculous yeah so here's the thing I
have a bird
I cannot saundra I'm way to bugs I'll
wait to [ __ ] that is his vs. yeah
doctor you take it to the doctor man
he's good the human make up to live like
calls cuz I remember so many calls that
I had to make four possums well this is
specifically called wildlife rescue
center you were maybe you're just animal
control wildlife rehabilitation center
of northern Utah it's funny that they're
drunk and they're sending to rehab rehab
so they named them would have done the
bird a bird the bird scooter no no too
dangerous [ __ ] hate those things you
know that oh yeah no one likes cuz you
just drive around LA and then like in
front of barbell I guess people use them
now they just throw them in the street
on the street yeah let's
yeah if yours it feels like the entrance
to barbell there's like five a pile of
five scooters right in the front like no
one parts them neatly they just like
Santa Monica that's where they should
have kept this everyone go no everywhere
you go out something there's like random
stores and they just [ __ ] together you
might even see one just walking down the
street one day it's like on the floor
out of nowhere yeah some cities banned
they get abused over someone's car got
hit too cuz I guess they didn't like
level a well and then it came and then
it dented the car fell down and hit the
car I don't even know how insurance
works with stuff like that yeah so this
bird bird they named him PD uber uber
uber and so they are saying that he's
three weeks old now and that big he's
eating very no recent pic huh did he get
a nice and pick I wanna see him
yeah before-and-after transformation
Tuesday picture I love when they do that
with like when they save abused puppies
or something they're like well we found
him he was malnourished and give him a
shower and everything yeah yeah they
look all like the about to die and then
it's like a new dog yeah look how happy
hmm well this was recent so I don't know
how much more time to Rend a picture of
a bird yeah yeah just give me anything
are you lie to me tip beautification
process is Gobert really different like
a white one she pulls up a chicken
dinner the Chinese one that's making me
hungry got any buns slow I can't pull
[ __ ] Nikki look like [ __ ] me I got this
like a different bird to that was like a
sparrow and they shoot [ __ ] bald
eagle and [ __ ] like yeah it's close
enough but it's pixelated because I
couldn't load it
we're gonna be left if they let him go
and a hunter goes where all right no no
that's not gonna happen
you have a picture of the hunted bear
put the five bullets through it I know
dinner do you think at these animal
rehab centers like in Asia like it's
called the restaurant they don't say
that in the fall time they will release
him into the wild you won't know how to
do anything from that person he looks
ready to go
Yeah right no cuz that was in the fall I
have this time-travel thing thank you
mmm almost ready he'll run into his
family and be like huh mom
son she's druggie though according to
Nikki oh yeah remember that book are you
my mother that book [ __ ] me up oh
that's that which book is so the baby
bird fell out of the nest and then it
went up to all these other animals one
by one like I went up to a cat and it's
like argh you my mother and the cats
like no and then I ran to the drunk guys
and I got you oh my god yeah I was like
odd so [ __ ] up from this what if I
could have fell in love how did it
affect you because of that are you guys
yeah I think I found his mother at the
end we didn't need that before going to
kindergarten or preschool in preschool
in preschool because I'm like maybe
that's where you kept crying well I was
three yeah that too I was in preschool
without my mother and I wanted her and I
learned how to read when I was three and
so I would bring my own dr. Seuss books
to read them to the class and that book
was like that was I did not want to read
that one again it's too emotional yeah
baby Bergkamp and is crying because it
can't find his mother
yeah you should have stuck to Hungry
Caterpillar
[Music]
[Music]